Short and sweet number eight. We discussed how Yayin Nesech, because it is tied to Avodah Zarah, it is considered one of the three cardinal sins which a person is not allowed to do even to save a life, even in a situation of Sakhanos Nefashos.
Therefore, in a situation where a doctor or someone would prescribe drinking Yayin Nesech to save a person's life, it would depend how the person or the doctor prescribed this medication, this Yayin Nesech.
If the doctor says, or the person says, drink Yayin Nesech in order to save your life, then that would be forbidden, and a person would unfortunately have to give up their life.
However, if the doctor or the person prescribing just says, drink wine, and the wine that they're saying to drink happens to be Yayin Nesech, but they don't say those words,
that is a situation where a person would be allowed to drink the Yayin Nesech in order to save their life.
We then discuss when it came to Stam Yeinam, because Stam Yeinam is only Durat Banan, so then it may be drunk or even applied externally for life-threatening situations.
In the case of Sakhanos Tafashos, we do waive Yisuri Durat Banan.
However, Stam Yeinam may not be drunk for a non-life-threatening situation.
If a person is sick, but it's not threatening their life, then they may not drink Stam Yeinam.
The question became, what about applying Stam Yeinam externally for a non-life-threatening situation?
That was a machokas. The Shulchan Aruch held that it's still forbidden.
However, the Rama said, in the case where it's non-life-threatening and it's only externally applied,
that would be a situation where it is permitted.
We then discussed the topic of yayin mevushel, of cooking wine.
So, if a person has a bottle of wine which is already considered Stam Yeinam, and it's already asr,
So then, we said, cooking it does not permit it, it's not going to take something which is already usher and make it permissible, however, if you have a bottle of kosher, or you have wine, which is kosher, and it's owned by a Jew, and it was cooked to a point where it's considered Yayin Mevushel, it is protected from becoming forbidden, even if a non-Jew would touch it, because we said, Yayin Mevushel, cooked wine, is not something that non-Jews libate, and therefore it is protected from being touched.
The one interesting case we came up with is, let's say you have a bottle of kosher wine, which was already Mavushel, and it's owned by a Jew, it's Mavushel, and it's sealed and ready to go.
But then that bottle was purchased by a non-Jew, and now the non-Jew owns the bottle of wine.
He doesn't just touch it, he actually takes ownership of it.
That became a machlokas, if it is forbidden or permitted to drink.
Rebbe Kiva Eger held that it is forbidden, even if they don't touch the wine, but the fact that they own the wine already prohibits it.
While the Rush of the Rambam and the Shulchan Aruch Passings of the Maisa, it would be permitted, even if they don't touch it.
We mentioned that a case that could come up is if a person's in a restaurant, a kosher restaurant, and their boss purchases a bottle of Yayin Mevushel,
in that case, are you allowed to drink the wine? That would be subject to this machokas.
We then discussed how most poskim hold that as long as the wine is heated to a temperature of Yad Tzeletisbo, it would be considered cooked.
However, some hold that the wine must be heated to a point where it evaporates slightly.
And lastly, when it came to pasteurized wine, there was a big machokas in the postgame, whether it's considered Mavushel or not, how hot it has to get, but we left it as a machokas, which we could use as a sniff the huckle, as a consideration, but it is ultimately a machokas.